joe biden's lead remains the same on the
electoral map it's 253-213 but in
georgia
he's taken a very very slim lead over
president trump after trailing since
election day
president trump is still ahead in
pennsylvania but that lead is narrowing
fast too
as more votes are counted there and in
nevada biden has led consistently over
the past few days but that lead has
well it's expanded in fact to just under
12 000 votes
60 in sixth correspondent enrique
acevedo
is in north las vegas for us following
the latest developments there
enrique good morning to you good morning
the nevada secretary of state says there
are a little over 190
000 outstanding ballots statewide and
around 90 percent of those are here in
clark county a democratic
stronghold we are told that later today
we can expect some updated results
later this afternoon about 51 000 of
those outstanding ballots
it could be a big boost for writing as
clark county is only one of two counties
in the entire state
where he maintains a steady lead
meanwhile a new complaint alleging voter
fraud was filed later thursday
in the state echoing claims the trump
campaign has been making
the lawsuit alleges the software being
used in clark county to verify voter
signatures
is not meeting minimum standards and it
calls for the county to stop using it
it also claims more than 3 000 instances
of uneligible voters
casting ballots and claims that in some
cases ballots were cast for deceased
voters
no documents to back either claim were
provided anthony and with that new batch
of results expected
later today we can see the voter count
in
nevada go to over 90 percent if we had a
soundtrack to describe
this process in the state it would sound
a lot like despacito
it's going very slowly but authorities
here say
they're aiming for accuracy not speed
anthony
accuracy is key enrique thank you very
much senator mcconnell
just weighed in on the vote count on
twitter he writes quote
here's how this must work in our great
country every legal vote should be
counted
any illegally submitted ballots must not
all sides must get to observe the
process
and the courts are here to apply the
laws and resolve disputes
that's how america that's how americans
votes decide the results
and we are joined now by nevada attorney
general aaron ford
attorney general ford good morning
thanks so much for being with us
uh as you just heard as you just heard
enrique say
there are allegations by the trump
campaign they filed a lawsuit claiming
that
some 3 000 improper ballots were filed
have you seen any evidence of voter
fraud in your state
we have not and nor has our republican
secretary of state barbara sagaski
nor have our 17 county registrars and in
fact
this six-page complaint that they found
late last night
is in a word garbage uh when you take a
look at the list that they presented
and they never presented me the list by
the way if you take a look at the list
of folks on that name one of the first
things that pops up
is that there are a lot of military
addresses on that list uh what that led
with our cover letter says is that it
appears as though these people may have
been properly
uh cast mailing ballots that's pure
speculation
and as evidenced by the fact that the
list itself has military people on it
it just goes to show the last efforts
that these guys are going to go through
to try to
derail this election campaign yeah as we
we just heard jim corden
james corden making some jokes about the
the vote counting in las vegas
uh referring to the fact that he was
right
referring to the fact that the casinos
are all open all night so why can't the
vote counting be i know we want accuracy
but the vote counting does appear to be
going slowly why so slowly
well it's going slowly because this is a
new endeavor for us to be sure
our legislature in its infinite wisdom
decided to mail all mack
have all active voters receive mail in
ballots this year so that they could
exercise a constitutional franchise to
vote
free from coping and most folks took
advantage of that and so it's taken time
to
receive and process these million
ballots which has built in redundancies
to prevent fraud
uh we have signature verification we
have a unique barcodes and we have other
other redundancies to ensure that we
don't have people who are voting twice
or otherwise and so that's why it's
taking longer uh and people are not
sleeping
i'm not sleeping i can tell you that
and what we're trying to do is to ensure
that we have uh
some accurate um results that are laid
out based on the voices that have been
raised
through this election cycle do you have
a sense when that when you might have a
final count
well what i do know is that uh there's a
november 12th deadline by which
joe gloria has indicated obviously he's
going to meet that's the local county
registrar
but all of our state registrars have to
meet that deadline i wouldn't be
surprised if it's met before that but
that's not my lane so to speak um i do
know that we're going to be getting uh
results in today as well and we will
have a better picture of
what the results look like at some time
around 9 or 10 o'clock today
what how significant in in terms of
number of votes do you expect that to be
well at a minimum of 51 if i 51 000.
that 51 51 000 is what i recall
uh someone saying on yesterday but again
that's more in the province of our
secretary of state our chief elections
officer
and the local registrars to talk about
that 90 of these votes that are being
tallied are coming out of clark county
which is where las vegas is located
which is
about two-thirds of the state's
population in any event uh and so
uh you know that that's what we're going
to be seeing talib and coming out
uh today at nine and at ten oh or ten
o'clock this morning all right attorney
general ford thank you so much for
joining us and i hope you get some sleep
we appreciate it
thank you